son ascension a été fulgurante sénateur
de l'illinois fraîchement élu il se
révèle en juillet 2004 au congrès
national du parti démocrate barack obama
devient le candidat démocrate à
l'élection présidentielle de 2008
lui qui quatre ans auparavant était un
illustre inconnu
la planète découvre un homme qui soulève
les foules mobilise les électeurs en
prêchant la réconciliation il espoir
séduit par sa verve et son message les
montréalais christine bourgier christien
kimbundu sont rapidement devenus
partisans de l'homme s'était ou un coup
de foudre vincent est là quelque chose à
faire et à dire ces gars là c'était la
guerre en irak c'était il y avait comme
une certaine morosité ambiante un
certain cynisme par rapport à la
politique et d'avoir ce ce jeune barack
obama c'est ça changera complètement la
donne barack obama s'est aussi démarqué
parce qu'ils n'étaient pas issus de
l'élite politique
il n'était ni à gauche ni à clinton va
commencer déjà par ça et il ya un refus
d où il ya eu un rejet de cette de ce
pouvoir dynastique qui s'était mise en
place depuis la fin des handicaps le
début des années 90
[Applaudissements]
le 4 novembre 2008 barack obama devient
président des états unis
si tout cet engagement social d'aller
vers un mieux vivre pour les pour les
américains
à l'époque christine christian et des
amis assistent aux mêmes à la cérémonie
d'investiture en janvier 2009
je me souviens j'étais jeune père donc
pour moi d'avoir quelqu'un à qui mes
enfants puissent identifier cetef
c'était vraiment sale image
dix ans plus tard barack obama at il
répondu à leurs attentes
il ya des points effectivement qui sont
décevants guantanamo notamment dans le
même temps vers la fin de son mandat il
ya eu un rapprochement avec l'iran avec
cuba oui touba macaire très bien mais
les inégalités ont continué de
s'accroître
malheureusement l'homme prudent qu'était
barack obama n'a parfois pas osé tranché
c'est vraiment l'histoire de sa
présidence c'était quelqu'un au vent
c'était quelqu'un qui était assez soft
qui ne tranchait pas qu'ils qui évitait
de prendre la prise de risque c'est
vraiment partir d'un bilan mitigé mais
pour moi le il a accompli ce qu'il avait
accompli
il souligne que le président n'a pas
toujours eu les coudées franches en
raison de l'opposition républicaine
alors que barack obama se voulait
rassembleur
les etats unis semblent encore plus
divisé qu'au moment de son élection
à partir du moment où il a été élu il
est certain que les groupes racistes
vraiment ceux qui ont des relents de
fascisme en vraiment connu une espèce de
d'appel d'air à ce moment là et
aujourd'hui à la veille des élections de
mi-mandat en fait tout ce que l'on
entend céder division une extrême
polarisation qui existait avant son
élection mais qui s'est accrue
finalement avec pendant son mandat pour
culminer avec l'élection de donald trump
et ces politiques là l'inclusion des
personnes trans dans l'armee obamacare
le rejet du projet de pipeline keystone
xl
on constate que la pérennité de son
héritage avec dans mon train pas la
maison blanche demeure incertaine
via twitter quoi qu'il en soit barack
obama aura réussi à devenir le premier
président noir de la première puissance
mondiale
[Applaudissements]